hey guys how's it going so book tour has
been really really amazing I'm just now
officially finishing up here with New
York and the New Jersey meetups so if
you guys are in Pittsburgh come hang out
June 5th I can't wait to see you guys
well be good Beaver Valley Mall at the
books-a-million
starting at 7:00 p.m. I feel like I've
always been handing my videos with my
little bedtime chats because as soon as
I get back home I'm like shoot I didn't
end my video here's New York News New
Jersey and on stay tuned for zamesca a
questions at the end so today is the
official day of my book launch and I'm
so excited cuz we're heading to our
first meetup which is in Tribeca what
I'm really also very excited about is
the little launch present that Mophie
made for me and I said a bunch of these
to my other fellow friends that I had
set books to it's an IJ movie and we
also are giving away three of them in
the book giveaway that I did which we'll
be announcing that winner along with the
winner of the MacBook and all the other
goodies very very soon we're about the
head out now to our side actually I
already signed so we're doing photos and
I'm gonna give them oh so many hugs
alright time for some bedtime chats ask
I J before I leave you guys here for my
next destination off to Pittsburgh can't
wait to see you guys
since Libby is on land again can you
roommate he just didn't come back he
just seen will come back I am so sorry I
forgot about her the iJustine book also
rocking my Apple watch hello
excuse you you are Bay I loved seeing
all of you guys tweet me pictures of my
book I thought together sort of like a
little collage of all of the ones from
day one but you guys tweeted me and it
was pretty freaking awesome it's kind of
insane to sort of see the book go out
into the world into your hands and see
you guys actually happened Rebecca wants
to know if I'm planning on writing
another book okay honey hold us hold
your horses no no I don't get wait to go
home to Pittsburgh so I can do some
laundry because I'm officially out of
clothes I'm having to UK for book tour
I'm hoping to do a UK tour I'm not sure
when but I'll let you know what's the
hardest part about writing my book
organizing my thoughts I think the
hardest part about any type of writing
or actually working on a big project is
kind of just starting so I think
actually getting started with it was the
most difficult thing you change the
color of my blood what color would you
choose and why I'm sorry excuse you
mister why are you trying to change me
why are you trying to change me I'm not
good enough for you I met you a book on
did you have fun
yes Emily I had an amazing time and
meeting you guys honestly brings so much
freaking just inspiration and happiness
to my life because when you're doing
this kind of stuff like making videos
and talking to a camera all the time and
you're not talking to a real person it
doesn't seem real until we do these
meetups and actually get to see you guys
and know how much it means to you to
meet us as well did you forget about the
iJustine forgot Twitter clearly has Bri
bought a copy of your book actually I
don't think she did well pic I never go
back to Georgia yeah I really wanted to
do Atlanta on this tour but I didn't get
a chance to because this tour also
coincides with III which is happening
laughs very very soon so I'll be d3
hopefully I'll see you guys there and I
think this might have been a long enough
ask i J because this could potentially
be a long video I'll see you guys in
Pittsburgh and then Chicago Dallas
Seattle and back in Los Angeles on the
13th so see you guys so freakin soon
thanks for being so supportive exes and
oh maybe just X's X's our hugs right
because I just want to make sure